Dear fellow scholars. This is two minute papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We have showcased this paper just a few months ago, which was about creating virtual characters with
a skeletal system, adding more depth
, 300 muscles, and teaching them to use these muscles to kick, jump, move around and perform
other
realistic human movements. It came with really cool insights as it could portray how increasing the amount of weight to be lifted changes what muscles are being trained during
the workout. These agents also learned
to jump really high and you can see a drastic difference between the movement required for a mediocre jump and an amazing one beyond that, it showed us how these virtual characters would move. If they were hamstrung by bone deformities, stiff ankle or muscle deficiencies, and watch them learn to walk. Despite these setbacks, we could even have a look at the improvements after a virtual surgery takes place.
So now how about an even more elaborate technique that focuses more on the
muscle simulation part?
The ropes here are simulated in a way that the only interesting property of the
particles holding them together is position Casa rat,
rod simulations are an improvement because they also take into consideration the
orientation of the particles and Hans can simulate twists as well.
And this new technique is called Viper and add a scale property to these
particles and hands takes into consideration stretching and
compression. What does that mean? Well,
it means that this can be used for a lot of muscle related simulation problems
that you will see in a moment. However,
before that an important part is inserting these objects into our simulations,
the cool thing is that we don't need to get an artist to break up these surfaces
into muscle fibers. That will not only be too laborious,
but of course would also require a great deal of anatomical knowledge. Instead,
this technique does all this automatically the process that the authors call
Viper ization.
So in goes the geometry and outcomes and nice muscle model.
This really opens up a world of really cool applications. For instance,
one such application is muscle movement simulation.
When attaching the muscles to bones, as we move the character,
the muscles move and contract accurately
tool, it can also perform muscle growth simulations
and three, we get more accurate soft body physics.
Or in other words, we can animate GUI characters like this octopus.
Okay. That all sounds great, but how expensive is this?
Do we have to wait a few seconds, two minutes to get this? Not at all,
not at all.
This technique is really efficient and runs in milliseconds so we can throw in a
couple of more objects.
And by couple a computer graphics researcher always means a couple of dozen
more, of course. And in the meantime,
let's look carefully at the simulation timings.
It starts from around eight to nine milliseconds per frame.
And with all these octopi,
we are still hovering around 10 milliseconds per frame.
That's a hundred frames per second,
which means that the algorithm scales with the complexity of the scenes really
well. This is one of those rare papers.
It is written both very precisely and it is absolutely
beautiful. Make sure to have a look in the video description.
The source code of the project is also available with this.
I hope we'll get even more realistic characters with real muscle models in our
computer games and real time applications. What a time to be alive.
This episode has been supported by Lambda. If you are a researcher or a startup,
looking for cheap GPU compute to run these algorithms,
check out Lambda GPU cloud. I've talked about Lambdas,
GPU workstations in other videos,
and I'm happy to tell you that they are offering GPU cloud services as well.
The Lambda GPU cloud can train image net to 93% accuracy for
less than $19.
Lambda's web based IDE lets you easily access your instance right in your
browser.
And finally hold onto your papers because the Lambda GPU cloud costs less than
half of AWS and Azure.
Make sure to go to Lambda labs.com/papers and sign up for one of their
amazing GPU instances today. Uh,
thanks to Lambda for helping us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous support. And I'll see you next time.